you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news
on today's special earth day programme
president joe biden says the u.s will
cut greenhouse gas emissions by at least
50 percent by the end of the decade as
he opens the global leaders summit on
climate change
our earth day is being marked around the
world from flash mobs in indonesia
to wearable art and the bangladeshi
engineer
using the sun to power three wheelers in
dhaka
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and meet those coming up with the
solutions and we aim to take you to the
heart of the climate crisis
explain the data driving the changes
that are already affecting us
but also show you just how far we've
come today is
earth day a global event to mark the
birth of the modern
environmental movement and to coincide
with that leaders from 40 countries are
taking part in a summit
on climate change it's being hosted by
u.s president
joe biden as he seeks to reclaim the
climate leadership
after four years of donald trump with a
key announcement
well in a moment we'll hear from our
climate correspondent hannah thomas
peter who's in washington
but first there were plenty of
announcements today including
president biden has committed to cutting
the united states gas
greenhouse gas emissions by more than 50
percent by 2030
compared to 2005 levels xi jinping said
china will start to phase down coal
consumption
from 2026 as part of its efforts to
reduce
greenhouse gas emissions canada has set
a new target
to reduce emissions by 40 percent to 45
percent by 2030
compared with 2005 levels and russian
president vladimir putin said there was
an
active effort in his country to build
more
legislation around tackling climate
issues
well leaders from around the world are
taking part in the summit so here's a
flavor of what they had to say
i talk to the experts and i see the
potential for a more
prosperous and equitable future the
signs
are unmistakable the science is
undeniable
but the cost of inaction is keeps
mounting
the united states isn't waiting china
will strive
to peak carbon dioxide emissions before
2030
and achieve carbon neutrality before
2016.
china has committed to move from carbon
peak to carbon neutrality
let's use this extraordinary moment
and the incredible technology that we're
working on
to make this decade the moment
of decisive change
well our climate correspondent hannah
thomas peter is in washington for us so
hannah president biden kicking off his
summit with a big commitment
yes and although 40 world leaders were
virtually present this was really joe
biden's show wanting to tell the world
that america
is back on the issue of climate change
making this
big commitment more than doubling the
promise to reduce
carbon emissions by 2030 to get to net
zero
by 2050 and it's had the effect of
galvanizing
a really significant sense of momentum
and ambition he's been backed up by the
world's major economies big polluters
the uk in the last couple of days of
course making its own pledge
the eu doing the same but as you
outlined there japan canada
and south korea all coming forward with
more the issue though
is at the course of garnering genuine
international consensus and collective
action
under extreme pressure never did run
smooth and so there's big question marks
over china
will it ever be able to move its
commitments will it ever be able to do
more at the moment it seems intransigent
india is the same russia being very
vague about what it is willing to do and
the science is telling us that this next
decade of action
cannot be a decade of action unless
every single country in the world
in particular those big polluters
managed to act
in concert hannah stay with us because i
want to bring in our economics editor ed
conway and ed you've been looking at the
challenges that are facing these
countries haven't you because
when we're talking about net zero you
know what is that carbon emissions total
we're actually trying to reduce and when
you
look at total global emissions i've got
it here in this uh this doughnut it
shows you basically total
greenhouse gas emissions about 50
billion tons of co2
but when you look and kind of delve into
what sectors are actually producing
those emissions you get some interesting
results so for instance land use that's
kind of agriculture primarily
almost 20 so almost a fifth of it but
most of it is energy and when you kind
of just
drill down into where we're actually
spending that energy some things are
quite striking so for instance you know
we talk a lot don't we about
aviation you know how aviation we need
to think about what we're you know
flying
we need to do potentially less of it but
actually there is more co2
coming from the production of cement
than from aviation actually more coming
from cement than coming from
deforestation
so it's worth just underlining you know
we do focus a lot when talking about
deforestation on
aviation but actually we need to think
about how we can get green cement and
it's the same thing actually when you
kind of drill down into that kind of
energy segment we've got here this that
segment's just global emissions
look at domestic emissions so that's
just in you know eight billion people
more or less across the
uh the world about 10.9 percent of those
emissions are coming from those homes
but now look compare that kind of
billions of people with a few thousand
steel and chemical plants actually it's
the same emissions from both so
you need to look not just at the stuff
that we're kind of publicizing uh
trying to get that down but also at you
know industry and trying to remake the
industrial revolution and that matters
not just around the world but it matters
for the uk as well because when you look
at total uk emissions well that's kind
of us getting down to net zero
with our domestic emissions down by
about 35 percent so far
but look not just at that but at the
stuff that we're importing from overseas
from china from europe from other parts
of the world
and it's a lot higher our total carbon
footprint when you include
those imported emissions is much higher
and it's going to be much harder it's
come down about 30
it's gonna be much harder though to get
it down to zero so there is a big
difference between what we're talking
about with net zero
and the actual emissions uh in our
footprint thanks very much indeed
so let's bring hannah thomas peter back
in now and
talking of the uk hannah we heard from
boris johnson at the summit of course
and the uk has made its own big
commitments this week hasn't it
it has to reduce its carbon uh
its uh emissions by uh 78
by 2035 a big commitment uh
wound into into legislation which makes
it different from other countries have
non-binding
targets i thought it was very
interesting at the beginning of his
speech that boris johnson
actually spent some time trumpeting the
uk's achievements
perhaps unwilling to relinquish the
limelight the spotlight
the leadership mantle to the us with an
eye of course
on that big u.n climate meeting summit
in glasgow in november later this year
but boris johnson
also pivoted in the second half of his
speech
to something even more important which
was to talk really to his domestic
audience it's something you heard joe
biden do too which is that
tackling the climate crisis can mean
opportunity it can mean growth it can
mean
green jobs as well as a healthier
happier life for the people
of the united kingdom climate change
doesn't have to be about sacrifice and
going without
expect to hear much more of that
messaging as the year advances
hannah thank you well 2020 was the
warmest year on record in europe
according to a new
report and last year greenhouse gas
emissions were at their highest levels
since satellite observations began
in 2003. ahead of today's earth day
summit eu countries agreed to reduce
their emissions by
55 percent by 2030 but some member
states
are less willing to move away from
fossil fuels
poland still produces around
three-quarters of its
electricity from coal and the country is
home to the most polluting power plant
in europe and adam parsons joins me now
live from bell hat off
power plant now so adam a challenge for
poland to bring its emissions down
a huge challenge if you want to see the
real
difficulty in cutting an addiction to
fossil fuels look at this
first you got this ravaged landscape
which has been chiseled apart over
decades in order to get
pretty dirty brown coal from there and
that brown coal
is fed into that big belching
monstrous power plant over there bell
hat off the biggest polluter
in europe every second it goes through a
ton
of coal and yet you can't just switch
that off because that
single power station is delivering 20
of poland's uh electricity need and this
is a
nation that uses coal relentlessly
three-quarters of its electricity
comes from coal and at the same time
look at those big chimneys
over there 300 meters tall and
pumping out a toxic blend of
exhaust gases poland will have to move
away from coal
but it's going to be costly it's going
to take a long time
and the country's political well well
it's not
quite there yet i think adam thank you
and there's plenty more from around the
world on earth day and the biden summit
on our climate cast podcast this week's
episode is out tomorrow and you can find
it wherever you normally get your
podcast from
so let's take a look now at what's else
is happening in climate news and arrests
have been made after extinction
rebellion activists broke windows at
hsbc's headquarters in london the
protesters say
they want to expose the banking system
and its investment in fossil fuel
hsbc say they're aiming to be a net zero
bank by 2030
and are committed to supporting their
customers as they become more
sustainable
the duke of cambridge is urging people
to recognise the part they must play
to help to save the planet prince
william has called on the public to use
the same dedication shown in the
coronavirus pandemic
to fight climate change the duke
launched a 50 million pound earth shot
prize in october
to recognize innovative ideas and
technologies
[Applause]
and activists in indonesia are
celebrating earth day in style
passers-by were taken by surprise as
environmental campaigners performed a
flash mob
in jakarta to raise awareness of climate
issues
they're calling on the indonesian
government to take action to fulfill
their commitments on climate
change coming up after the break why an
engineer
is trying to change the way dakar's
three-wheelers
are powered
welcome back to a special edition of the
daily climate show
now we're all about solutions on this
program but some ways to address the
causes of climate change are more
controversial than
others addressing the leader summit
earlier boris johnson talked about
carbon capture it's a way of removing
co2 emissions from the air and many see
it
as an important part of the net zero
process
but for others the focus should be on
reducing what we're releasing into the
atmosphere in the first place
so here's how it works
so co2 that was in the environment
yesterday is in this pipe today
[Music]
[Music]
see if you still have to fill up the
holes and then this is what it looks
like after
[Music]
so carbon capture is a possible solution
to help reduce
emissions and tech like it can make a
difference to the pace of climate change
but however fast we move now our climate
is
changing so while the leaders of today
grapple with the challenges of tomorrow
there's also the need to adapt to the
changes that we're already experiencing
well joining me now to discuss this
further is american climate scientist
professor michael
mann he's distinguished professor of
atmospheric science at penn state
university
and author of the new climate war and dr
cece who
climate researcher from harvard law
school so welcome to both of you
cece if i can start with you we're
hearing an awful lot today about
targets on emissions reduction is that
the right focus or should more attention
be given to adapting and giving
resources
to adapting life to a world that's
already experiencing
changing in temperatures and climate at
the moment um i think
there has not been enough attention paid
to adaptation and if you
you know watch the summit earlier on uh
most of the leaders addressed the
question of mitigation
and most of the developing country
nation leaders addressed the
question of adaptation so adaptation is
hugely important
because even if we freeze all of our
emissions right now
we have sort of locked ourselves into a
certain level of warming already because
the earth is basically filled with water
and water takes a long time to heat up
so that means we are effectively
locked in to a certain amount of warming
regardless of what we do
and that is why adaptation is hugely
important and more attention should be
focused on that issue
michael you're talking to us from the us
and president biden has clearly made
climate change a big priority what about
though
helping the rest of the world and those
parts of the world worst hit by climate
change and
already experiencing problems yeah well
we have an obligation to do that
um my friend john holdren the former
presidential science advisor under
barack obama
once put it very aptly when it comes to
our response to the climate crisis
we have three options mitigation
preventing
further climate change adapting to those
changes
that are already inevitable those
impacts that are already inevitable
and suffering and we want to minimize
suffering and in part what that means
is that those of us um in the industrial
world
countries like the united states that
have this legacy of
two centuries of access to cheap uh
dirty energy
we have an obligation to help other
countries um
like india uh the rest of uh the
developing world to
first of all leap frog past the fossil
fuel stage
so they don't have to go through it we
need to provide them resources
renewable energy access uh to do that
and we need to help them out provide
them resources
to give them greater resilience and ceci
i could see you nodding there so how
should those resources be spent what are
the best examples
of adaptation a really good example
of climate adaptation i think is a case
of um let's say in the uk um the uh high
speed
uh two rail net rail network which is
supposed to run between london
and birmingham and leeds and it's
supposed to be the biggest you know
second biggest
um rail network in europe once it's
constructed
but what they did for in terms of
adaptation was
looking at these two aspects right one
looking at very very detailed high level
the best
climate models there is to like to
basically
uh locate the um systems where they're
most vulnerable
and then the second thing that they did
was use this technique called what-if
scenarios
so basically they laid out all of the
worst case scenarios to
or the case scenario in terms of
flooding in terms of you know different
natural disasters
and how they're going to interact with
climate change and basically come up
with a set of procedures
as to okay scenario a is going to happen
this is a set of procedures that you
have to follow
scenario b you know we can never predict
the future
but it does mean that if we take this
kind of adaptive
approach it means that we have a sense
of how the future might unfold
and we are prepared for it and michael
mann very briefly
do you feel optimistic the real change
is on the way
i do um today is earth day we have new
leadership in the united states in the
form of the biden administration
the united states has reasserted its
role in addressing the climate crisis
and that's bringing
other nations along and so i'm
optimistic that this week
in washington dc at this climate summit
we're going to see a significant
ratcheting up of those commitments that
the countries of the world have made to
lower
carbon emissions to get us on a path
that does limit warming
below a catastrophic one and a half
degrees celsius there's still
time to do it there are no obstacles
other than
political will and political support
well professor michael mann and dr cece
who thanks very much indeed both
well also today the owner of british
airways says it'll power
10 of its flights with sustainable fuel
by 2030.
international airline group said it
plans to buy one million
tons of sustainable aviation fuel each
year which produces up to 70
less carbon than fossil fuels the group
is aiming to reach net zero carbon
emissions by 2050.
[Applause]
engineers in scotland are using plastic
waste to get into space
aerospace company skyrora has developed
a new aviation fuel
made from non-recyclable materials which
would otherwise go
to landfill they estimate they could
save 300 tons of plastic waste by 2030
and the world's most powerful climate
computer is being built in the uk
the met office is working with microsoft
to create the system
which they say will provide more
accurate weather forecasting
and a better understanding of climate
change it's expected to be one of the
top 25
supercomputers in the world when it's up
and running next month
and a reminder that you can watch our
weekly digital show from tomorrow it's
available
on sky news social channels our app and
our website
now three wheelers are one of the most
popular forms of transport in bangladesh
they're mostly electric
but the energy used to charge them is
produced almost entirely by burning
fossil fuels
such as oil and gas well bangladeshi
engineer gopal kumar mahoto
wants to do his bit for the climate
crisis by getting dakar's electric
vehicles
off the dirty energy grid and onto solar
power
[Music]
hello i am gopal mahoto from bangladesh
i am an engineer and i am co-founder of
cassettes
castex is a fully operated solar powered
battery shopping station service for
electric last mile transport
electric vehicles cannot be considered
fully environment friendly
unless their source of energy is from
renewable sources
our customers can swap multiple times a
day
and they pay the energy bill through
mobile banking
in the last 25 years i have witnessed
the fastest growth in technology
i feel there is no value of all this
innovation
or solution if it's not sustainable the
only way
for what i see is to take rapid action
right now wherever we can we are
determined to divert
at least 250 000 vehicles from the
fossil fuel driven national grid
to renewable we have the tools needed to
fight climate change
now it's our responsibility so let's
find a way
to take action we are running out of
time to act on climate
we cannot afford to wait
well that's everything from this special
edition of the daily climate show
tomorrow it's day two of the summit and
we'll be speaking to the eu's executive
vice president
for the european green deal and we'll
have a special report on people in china
forced to relocate because of rising
temperatures
that's at the same time tomorrow join us
[Music]
then